uh welcome to today's planning committee
meeting uh there are six applications on
the agenda with the report on planning
appeals I am happy with this and intend
to take the business in the order set
out on the agenda
the first item is apologies for absence
have we received any advance yes chair
we've received apologies from councilor
and Morley who is being substituted by
councilor Sega
which will
are there any other apologies
non-received chair
members are requested uh to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other other
interests not already on their register
of interest in any item on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time do any members have any
interest to declare
item three on the agenda with them is
the minutes of our last meeting held on
the 6th of June this year
are we happy that they are a correct
record
is there a mover
on second all those in favor
all those are games
any abstentions
okay
motion is carried
that brings us to the main business for
the meeting our six applications before
we start I would like the clerk to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
and we will deal with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure I think
considering the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
there are seven speakers registered to
speak today
they will be speaking on the second and
fourth applications
speakers will have three minutes to put
forward their views
there'll be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from this point
the chair will open up the meeting for
questions to officers a date a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you
let's move on to the first application
application for the construction of two
dwellings resubmission of application
two two four slash zero one one two four
forward slash FL amended funds
additional information at 24 long Edge
Lane wingworth
in line with our normal practices I'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about uh late comments and to
give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site I will
allow the officers to complete the
presentation consequently members unless
you have any point of order that you
feel cannot wait could you please
reserve these or any questions about the
process until the end
thanks Chad
I'm Grant Cooper planning officer for
the council for anybody who's not not
met me yet so I'm going to go through
the first two items so this first item
is that this is a full application as
chairs just pointed out for the
construction of two dwellings in the
grounds of one two four long Edge Lane
at wingwith
a single late representation has been
received from wingworth Parish Council
and these comments can be read in full
in the late reps report that have been
provided to members before the meeting
so the main issues for this application
are the impacts on the proposed
developments on the character and
appearance of the street scene the
Heritage impacts impacts on neighbors
and Highway Safety
and there are no statutory Consultants I
have identified any technical reasons as
to why the application should be refused
so this first slide illustrates the
application site shaded in Orange
the site is set within the settlement
development limit of wingoweth and this
is in a residential setting
from the application site to the south
and east
and you've got Lodge Drive which extends
east down the hill and you've got hollow
Park School that you can just see to the
east of the application site
and also you've got the All Saints
Church to the southeast and that is a
list of building
so this is a location plan of the site
submitted with the application you can
see the site edged in red
you can see the relationship with the
neighboring properties you've got number
one two two long Edge Lane to the north
and you've got number one two six
longest Lane to the West
of these properties are two-story in
nature opposite the site to the east
we've got a pair of semi-detached
properties
and we've also got some detached
Bungalows further along the language
Lane to the Northeast
so the churchyard
sits to the south of the application
site and the church is probably about 75
meters away to the southeast
so this next slide this shows the
proposed site layout you've got plot one
which will sit to the west of number one
two four millfield on Long Beach Lane
and this will have a new access created
onto language Lane as well as you can
see on the plans
the existing access into the application
site will be closed up and a new access
created which will share between the
existing dual link and plot 2 to the
north
the plan illustrates the original
dwellings Garden
divided into three all of these Gardens
will meet the minimum private Garden
sizes set out in the council's
successful places SPD with the smallest
Garden being approximately 140 square
meters
so this next slide illustrates the
proposed house site but this is the
proposed floor plan and elevations
Easter Island will have three bedrooms
now this plan this is a levels plan
which have been submitted by the
applicant to try and help us understand
the levels comparison between the
application site the proposed running
and the neighboring dwellings so that
top drawing that you can see illustrates
plot one in the center
with existing dwelling on the right hand
side and number one two six on the left
the bottom drawing illustrates plot two
again in the center with existing
dwelling one two four on the left and
number one two two on the right
the proposed Ridge Heights will sit
between the existing built form on
luggage Lane quite comfortably as you
can see from the diagram
So Yesterday Shad remembers a full Suite
of photographs taken from site the next
few are just a selection of those that
are key to the decision
so this first one is taken from the
entrance of the churchyard looking back
towards the application site
the existing dwelling can be seen behind
the big tree there that is still there
on site today
number one two two can be seen on the
right hand side and number one two six
on the left down the hill
so this next photo is just a close-up
view of the the application site the
existing dwelling that's there on the
site
so this next photo is a close-up view of
the
one two six which sits to the west of
the application sites the garage you can
see in the photo will be removed from
sites if permission is granted
and that will be to accommodate plot one
that's proposed
so this final photo shows the
relationship between the existing
property on site and number one two two
on the right hand side there and plot
two will sit between between the two
properties and that concludes the
presentation chair
thank you
all right colleagues we have no speakers
on this application we will move
straight to questions to the officers
again I would like to keep this part of
the proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points you are not
sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all that we've heard and read
however grateful if you could not move
any motions at this stage let's wait
until we are all at a chance to make our
assessment
it's all open the floor the questions to
the officers
no questions for officers
right I'll uh thank you
um this leads us to the final part of
the process our discussion about what we
have heard
uh what we think and what we want to
decide before going any further I would
just like the clip to remind us about
motions
thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to emotion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officers recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed that doesn't mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timing of the Motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard and read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached thank you chair
thank you
um right along the floor for debate
okay
David thanks chair um I mean my concerns
with this is is how close they are to
the adjoining the adjoining premises and
plot one particularly is very very close
to to Pro to the property at one two six
um and I think
I think it needs it needs to go back I
mean it's kind of like the existing
property has protected Itself by keeping
a significant amount and it has
literally plant these writing it pretty
much up to the boundaries for the for
the neighboring neighboring properties
so I think it needs it needs revisiting
on that basis alone I think um there is
significant loss of amenities to the uh
to the two Neighbors on the other side
um I noticed they've improved the
windows which is good because that was
another concern but I'm just not
comfortable with the with the plots and
how close they are to uh to The
Neighbors at one two six and one two two
anybody else
hate them thank you chair I'm not sure
I'm in agreement with removing a garage
to put a plot up
I mean you're looking at yeah it is
quite a large lump and but it's bang on
a junction I'm not entirely sure how the
how the new accesses are going to work
and um I'm with David I think they're
going to be too overbearing on the
street seeing the density of mass in as
they've said in wingworth's neighborhood
plan
thank you
uh let's do it
there's a question for Graeme really
in terms of waiting obviously hearing
what counts like Hancock cancel Elliot
has just said in terms of waiting what
would that have if this was refused
today what would that impact would they
those comments have
um if we refused anyone to appeal
in terms of waiting it can just
as in the material weight those concerns
would have if it was sent back so yeah
obviously the the material
considerations are those laid out in the
local plan and the Winger neighborhood
plan in officer's opinion the proposed
development for two detached dwellings
fits within that it's a very mixed
Street Scene you know the neighboring
property has a projecting Gable
as numerous different sizes of openings
uh the proposed dwellings kind of in our
opinion fit in with the the character of
the area so you know if members are
minded to refuse the application
you know our view is that you know that
would be difficult to defend for the
council
thank you thank you chair
is everyone done on the debate right
um have we got an emotions having heard
everything uh today the offers a
recommendation before us what is a
review of the committee on the
application um no the out opening the
floor to motions
David
I'm going to move that we reject
officers recommendations based on the
fact that it doesn't comply with
wingerhoods with wingwood's neighborhood
plan under policy W1 for the
distribution and also
um on W4 that it doesn't really make the
mix of housing that's needed either
right members we have a motion before we
move to the vote sorry chair no one is
second at the moment sorry
I'll be your second without motion
no
well I will move that we accept officers
recommendations on this and Grant the
permission as laid out in the report
right can we take a vote on that please
so the motion chair then is to approve
operations recommendations are set out
in the report
councilor Chisholm
look
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliott
councilor forces
for
counselor Foster or
councilor girl
oh
Angela Hancock against
or
councilor Lacy for
councilor ligate oh and councilor Rouse
that's nine for the ram motion and two
against the motion as pasture
thank you
right we'll now move on to the second
application item five on the agenda uh
Ned or slash 23 stroke forward slash
zero zero zero twenty five forward slash
FL Clay Cross
the comment and give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site
I'll allow the officers to complete
their presentation consequently members
unless you have any point of order that
you feel cannot wait could you please
reserve please or any other any
questions about the process until the
end
right I believe you're leading this one
again Graham thank you
thanks Jeff
so as chair has just pointed out this
proposal is for a change of use of
agricultural land to form a glamping
sites and six touring Caravan pictures
off Mill Lane at homegate
a number of late reps have been received
which again have been reported to
members prior to the meeting but I've
just got a couple of uh points of
important matters I just need to point
out to chair and members of the
committee
so first of all we've updated the title
in agreement with the applicant just to
include the reference to the six six
pitches for touring Caravans
and at 1.1 and 4.9 of the officer
reports members the call in reason and
comments of the local War member were
incorrect
and have been just transferred through
from a different plan application so
apologies for that that mistake just in
order to clarify
the exact Ward member comments and
calling reason members will find the
updated sections of the officer reports
members in the late reps pack
also in the interest of completeness
I've offered to read out councilor
Cooper's original objection letter so
it's all right if I just read that out
so these are mem these are member
councilor Cooper's comments from
February earlier this year
so primarily her concerns are similar to
the recent planning refusal further down
Mill Lane on a different site
I'm concerned that this application
would be an intrusion into what is
currently open Countryside and Beyond
the settlement development limit of
homegate
I'm concerned that the proposals do not
mitigate the harmful urbanizing impact
this development could have on what is
currently a visually rural area
in addition given the rural and narrow
nature of the roads in this area I'm
concerned about the highways impacts of
the increased traffic in this area
particularly given the proposed pitches
as well as the potential parking issues
from the number of vehicles generated
finally I understand nearby residents
are concerned by the potential immunity
issues of this proposal in terms of
noise and other disturbance
I therefore object to this application
and given the concerns regarding the
impact it would have on the landscape
and surrounding infrastructure
if it is not monitor for refusal under
delegate Powers by officers I would
request that the application is
considered and determined by a planning
committee
so that's what councilor Cooper had to
say an apologies for not including that
in the report so hopefully that's just
put that
to one side so in addition to this
update officer proposing that if members
are mined to Grant permission today that
the new and revised conditions set out
in the late representations pack are
also considered by members
these conditions seek to restrict the
use of the site the structures seek to
prevent static Caravans from being
placed on a site and ensure no touring
Caravans are kept on the site during the
winter months
the main issues for the application are
set out in the officer reports and
considered to be the principle of
development for visitor accommodation
the impact on the proposed developments
on the landscape character the Heritage
impacts on nearby list of buildings the
impacts on neighboring residence
immunity and Highway Safety
and again we've got no statutory
consultes have identified any technical
reasons as to why the application should
be refused
so I'll now move on to the slides
so this slide is the site shaded in
Orange the application site is set in
open Countryside which is designated in
the local plan as a secondary area of
multiple environmental sensitivity
the settlement development limit for
tucks and sits on the opposite side of
Mill Lane to the east
and the river runs from west to east
between the application sites and the
allotments that you can see just to the
north
Hemlock Cottage is a grade 2 Lister
building and is located to the south at
the junction of Mill Lane and homegate
Road
and also you can see a public
right-of-way
which extends from north to south direct
approximately 80 meters Northwest of the
application site
so this is the submitted location plan
with the site engine in red with all the
other land under the applicant's own
ship in blue
so this plan illustrates the proposed
site layout with the access taken from
Mill Lane in the Southeast Corner as you
can see a reception and toilet block
will sit flanking a car park
moving west across the site we've got
six Caravan pitchers
followed by three pods and then there's
a green Gap
and there's a communal cabin and then a
further three pods
at the back of the site
so this is just a bit more of a zoomed
in view of the site
you see on the left developments
including the car park the toilet block
and the reception around that site
entrance
the central part of the scheme can be
seen on the bottom right
and a rear extent of the scheme can be
seen in the top right of this slide
so this is more detailed plan of the
site entrance which illustrates the
access onto Middle Lane it illustrates
the parking of vehicles on an area
formed of grass Crete
because toilet block reception building
to the west of the parking area and the
Grass Creek driveway extends into the
application site and that only serves
the touring pitches and the first three
pods it doesn't go any further into the
site
so these next few plans are just
elevation and floor plans hopefully you
can just make them out so this is the
reception building and some of the pods
that are proposed Timber cladding is
proposed for these buildings
and again this is the proposed floor and
elevation details of some more of the
glamping pods
so this is these shower block units
again Timber clad will be used on this
building and a single story
so this is the grill cabin which is the
communal cabin set towards the rear of
the site
so this is elevational details for the
cabin units to the rear of the site just
for clarity the sauna details that are
referred to I believe have been removed
from this proposal
so next few slides just a quick few
slides from the site visits from
yesterday so this is the view from Mill
Lane looking back into the application
site you just see the allotments that
are there on the right hand side the
existing hedgerone Landscaping on the
left or that left edge of the site will
be retained
another view from Mill Lane application
site on the right you've got some
Residential Properties which back onto
Middle Lane on the left hand side
and so this final photos taken from the
public right-of-way this is to the north
of the application site and the arrow is
to just try and indicate roughly where
the proposed development will extend on
that tree line
and that concludes the presentation
check
thank you
right colleagues we have four speakers
on the application the first whom will
be Trevor Watson an objector they will
have three minutes to get their point to
get over their points they'll be
informed when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them for to
clarify any matters that they have been
that they have raised but remember your
question should only relate to the
points which they have already made
so can I invite Mr Watson up to the
table please
Just for information you just press the
little button on the microphone to speak
right you've got three minutes for
sports good day to you all my name is
Trevor Watson my wife and I live in one
of six properties on Mill Lane opposite
Bateman's Mill Pub we and our neighbors
have several serious concerns about the
proposal
The Proposal fails to give any idea
about the number of visitors at any one
time and the number of weeks or months
per year that the site will be in
operation if in operation all year round
the proposal will effectively seeks
permission for housing in open
Countryside which will be subject to
much more stringent planning laws
previous applications near this site for
development have been refused by the
council and by inspectors on appeal
noting that the proposals would result
in a prominent intrusion into the open
Countryside and would erode the
separation between built up settlement
Edge and the open Countryside the same
applies with this application
with six pods and six parking spots for
Caravans and motorhomes there could be
30 to 40 visitors each and every week
this gives much cause for concern at the
likelihood of noise and disturbance in
what is at present a calm and tranquil
area in open Countryside at all times of
day and night the proposal States the
site will be far from any settlement and
the road which is clearly not correct
sound carries very readily across open
land the pods furthest from the site
entrance are closer to our settlement
than they are to the reception building
the public footpath mentioned twice in
the report with encouragement to utilize
it to reach the local pub in other
amenities runs directly past L and our
neighbors properties the boundary of the
footpath is also the boundary of our
house and garden
we're genuine concern about our Safety
and Security and the potential for
considerable disturbance and noise from
many revelers using this route at all
hours at present it's not a busy
footpath it's used by local dog walkers
as in fact calming peaceful
there are a number of conditions in the
planning officers report which would
appear to be unenforceable for instance
no barbecues outside the designated
block no fires no noise outside of
specified hours 24 hour on-site
management presence if the Assumption of
the planning team is that all the stated
conditions must be met in order for the
proposal to be approved if some
conditions are unenvossible then surely
the application cannot be approved
thank you for allowing me to speak to
you all today I appreciate your due
consideration of the points I've made
thank you very much any members have got
any questions
nope thank you
the next speaker is Mr Thomas
thank you everyone uh my wife and I are
the owners of handball Cottage the grade
to listed asset dating from 1699
that's most directly impacted by the
proposed development uh we contend there
are three eras of fact and policy in the
officers report of this committee
first the report takes a narrow and
restricted understanding of the phrase
the setting of a listed building
there is a court of appeal decision from
2016 which makes it quite clear this is
not an issue of physical proximity
that decision overturned planning
permission for Housing Development 1.5
kilometers to the south of a listed
building
Justice Lang quashed the decision on the
ground that the inspector had adopted an
unlawfully narrow approach to the
question of the setting of a listed
building by focusing on finding a visual
connection between the two
the court found that under the national
policy planning framework the
surroundings in which a Heritage asset
are experienced is not limited by the
sense of sight
the surroundings of a listed building
includes its physical surroundings and
The Wider experience of the Heritage
asset in its physical location
historic England draws attention to both
noise and Tranquility as aspects of the
setting of a listed building
we have a report from the planning
inspectorate in 2020 in connection with
an adjacent development I quote from
John Williamson the planning inspector
quote I consider the surroundings within
which henmore Cottages experienced
include the section of Mill Lane that
passes by the site to join homegate Road
and the land either side of it
a significant part of the listed
building setting is the appeal site and
the adjoining open Countryside to the
West which the site Falls part of
I consider this forms part of the list
of the list of buildings setting
and contribute substantially to the
significance of the listed building the
close quote
so our first contention is on the basis
of case law and the planning inspector
its prior decision the report gives an
incorrect assessment of the impact of
this development on a listed building
secondly the officer's report contains a
material error effect it refers to the
use of an existing adjacent Palisade
fence to screen the proposed development
this fence was erected as part of an
unauthorized development and is
currently subject to enforcement action
by this very Council
30 seconds remain it is procedurally
improper to take into account this
unauthorized development uh to further
to damage the setting the listed
building
finally the highways report ignores a
substantial material fact named in the
last decade hanwell Cottages has been
struck twice by Vehicles traveling along
the lane as part of its statutory duty
to protect a listed building the
council's obliged to mitigate this risk
and not to permit developments that
exacerbate the risk by encouraging
further traffic of large Vehicles that's
time share
thank you Mr Thomas do any colleagues
have any questions
no right we'll move on to the next
speaker uh Laura argard the applicant
hello three minutes when you're ready
okay dear planning committee members my
name is Laura Hoggard I have lived in
the community all my life and my family
have worked and farmed this land for
more than half a century I have always
enjoyed going down to the field and
helping with the cows and spending time
watching my dad on the tractor this
means a lot to me to keep in the family
for my children to enjoy the same
experiences I did we have conducted
extensive research on different options
and we believe that the glamping site
with the most sustainable farming farmer
diversification by maintaining the
landscape and bringing numerous benefits
not only to the local economy but to
Residents and visitors alike as many of
you may know a Glam damping a fusion of
glamor and camping has gained immense
popularity in recent years becoming
thriving tourism Trend around the world
glamping off his unique and high quality
camping experience that combines the
joys of being surrounded by Nature with
the confident Elegance of upscale
accommodations firstly a glamping site
would attract a diverse range of
tourists from families to couples
encouraging them to explore our
community in surrounding areas
however the site being small will
attract a variety of visitors that will
not adaptively stimulate local
businesses such as restaurant shops and
recreational facilities resulting
increased revenues and job opportunities
for our residents moreover a glamping
site aligns perfectly with our
commitment to environmental
sustainability by offering cabins
equipped with eco-friendly features we
can provide a unique experience for
visitors to zoo seeking to connect with
nature while minimizing their
environmental impact this initiative
will also present an opportunity to
educate visitors about sustainable
practices
but further familiarity and ecological
Consciousness within our community in
order to ensure a successful glamping
site will still be farming the remaining
land with grazing of cattle and planting
of wildflowers we aim to introduce more
wildlife and its Landscaping the site by
adding natural screening to protect the
privacy of guests and enhancing the
visual impact from all aspects we will
prioritize eco-friendly construction
materials and energy efficient systems
to address concerns about potential
noise or disturbance we pledge to
implement strict noise control measures
and curfews our priority is to create an
atmosphere that allows guests to
peacefully enjoy their surroundings
while respecting the Tranquility of our
community we understand that the
development proposal require raises
questions and concerns however we are
committed to an open dialogue with all
members of our community we firmly
believe that transparency and effective
communication are key to reaching a
positive outcome for everyone involved
in conclusion 30 seconds remain in
conclusion the establishment of a
glamping within our community presents
an exciting opportunity for growth
ecotourism and economic stimulation by
embracing this trend we can showcase our
Region's natural beauty while providing
new unique experience visitors we kindly
request your careful consideration of
our proposal and believe that together
we can create a glimp inside that
positively impacts our opportunity for
generations to come thank you for your
time and attention
thank you uh do any colleagues have any
questions
okay councils I get yeah I just wondered
how you intend policing the noise issues
we're going to put perfumes on and
they'll be on the terms of conditions
when people come they'll be like no
noise after 11 o'clock like most glimp
insights
so the policing will literally just be a
notice terms and conditions yes right
and if they do break that and we get
informed then they'll be asked to leave
probably oh
thank you
Angela thank you chair uh Miss hogard
thank you very much for your
contribution my question really is that
um more on the agricultural side I think
it sort of is well established that farm
farmers and the farming industry is
really struggling there's a lot of
challenges you mentioned the word
diversification quite clearly there and
that must be quite a serious
consideration
given the fact that the ownership of the
land has been in your family for quite
some time a note on there on the
application
it
something okay councilor Foster
if we can carry on
okay Miss Thomas heard the grade of the
land is obviously since he would have
taken into consideration I imagine so
that from your
um the way you've assessed it
this glamping site is going to enable
you to keep farming the land more
efficiently because you mentioned that
you can graze the cattle on it still
I know the lower part is subject to some
issues with flooding but the part you've
applied to isn't necessarily can you
just give us an Insight really on what
that means still being able to farm it
and how you came to the decision to
diversify okay so on I don't know if on
the diagram you saw how much of the
field is owned we also own two other
fields on their plans as well so my dad
still brings the cows down and we'll
have it fenced off so the cows can still
come as far down as possible to the
glamp and say and when we've been
visiting other glamping sites they love
to see the cattle in the field and my
dad's all still graze the land and mow
it for the kettle during the winter
but there's nothing else agriculture you
could do to get a better yield off the
land pardon sorry there's nothing else
in terms of Agriculture that you could
do to get a better return off the land
essentially this is gonna is this going
to help you run a more viable farming
Enterprise yeah we've looked at many
options and this is the only one that
will actually generate enough money to
be able to keep the land and that's what
we want to do thank you thank you
um no more questions thank you very much
uh that speaker is uh
Andrew Holmes also the African
well thanks
um I don't have a speech because Laura's
quite a lot
um
what I would like to take this
opportunity just to address a couple of
things
um
there's a gentleman what's always just
commented
um about some policy fencing that is not
our property what that has happened to
um
so I'd like you to consider that and
then the other thing is just following
on from the agricultural side the the
shape of the field makes it inefficient
to run the tractors
um when we're growing crops because you
get wastage because as you if you refer
back to the picture the outline of the
land Wiggles and obviously when you're
running farm machinery you want it as
straight as possible
um so for yields and things like that it
obviously restricts what you can get off
of there which obviously if we could
still graze cattle on there we could
still bail for silage on there but when
you're talking crops it's it's not as
easy
and that's all I want to say thank you
thank you uh any questions from the
speaker
thank you thank you very much for your
time
always we will now move uh we now have
the opportunity to put questions to
officers about the application
anybody got any questions for officers
cancel it just a question about uh
something about fencing and enforcement
I wonder what what that was to do with
right if you
if you look in the presentation pack
that's
only a second
on page 46 of the presentation figure
four
shows a proposed site plan
so if you just imagine you stood at the
site's entrance looking into the site
the passage fencing surrounds a site
neighboring this application
so it's on a separate third-party land
it is under investigation by the
enforcement team I've not had an update
as to where we are with that at the
moment
but I think the main consideration for
us as officers is that you know the
photos that we've shown during the
winter months and they were taken from
directly in front of the neighboring
neighbor inside and when you stand there
today looking up the site you can the
Hedgerow along that western boundary
is much more dense in its appearance and
there are a number of trees and I think
what we're trying to say is officers is
that on balance the proposed development
set against that mature hedge and trees
would have an acceptable impact on the
landscape character
so yeah so with regards to Palisade
fencing that is being looked into and it
is outside the application side well I
think I think for reference it is worth
you know the
offense could be erected up to two
meters
on that side so that's probably
something to weigh into into the mix as
well
thank you
any other questions for officers
nope
thank you
uh right I'm now like to open the full
for debate
um
thanks Chad I think this is probably out
of all of them this is the one I've
struggled with most because in principle
I think I like the idea I like the
design of it but I think it's just the
wrong place and I think we're setting a
dangerous precedent
or something like this outside the
settlement Gap and I know we're kind of
touching it to a policy to say we can
squeeze it in here but it does feel like
we're very much trying to squeeze it in
rather than being a legitimate argument
of putting it there
so I've not heard anything that makes me
think otherwise if I'm truthful so yeah
I think it's a nice idea I like it but I
can't support it on where it is
thank you
absolutely okay yeah a little bit a
little bit like uh councilor Hancock
um much the same actually and I'm also a
little bit
perturbed about the idea of Caravans on
a glamping site because I can see
they've tried to
um blend everything in with the
countryside uh with the green roofs and
the wooden cladding but then to stick
six Caravan pictures on the front seems
a bit
strange to me well that's my opinion
thank you
yeah cancel that I get that concern
sorry I get that concern uh understand
that has there been I'm just trying to
find it here was there a reference to a
restriction on those Caravans I'm just
trying to find the page
um
where that where that was I mean
sort of figuratively speaking if they
weren't there would that change the
material waiting of this whole
application
so yeah so what we've tried to do is
officers are just clarify the position
of how long we'd like the the pods used
and the Caravans use so on page right
it's 0.3 of the late reps report we've
got a revised condition about the
surface water drainage and we've also
got a couple of extra conditions
three extra conditions which you see to
you know no touring Caravan should be
occupied on any of the six tournament
pitches
that form power developments for a
period of no more than 28 days so that
restricts the number of days that they
can use those pictures and also it would
have no caravan pitches between the 1st
of November and 31st of March and that
no caravan shall be stored on site
at any time so we have we have tried to
to restrict that and we're also trying
to restrict the the use and occupation
of the pods as well it's 28 days just
try and tighten that up
okay did just have Interest canceled I
go like how do you feel about that the
Restriction of it
well it's it's still it's not really any
different is it apart from the been
opened it on there in the winter right
oh it says you're concerning the comings
and goings essentially
yeah on the on what and what it looks
like during the
summer months when more people are about
well
right I know that I realize the hedges
will be grown in the summer
uh but you're still gonna Caravans well
99.9 Caravans are white aren't this or
they do stick out rather okay
Joe if I may if I can just add something
on there
this is obviously I think the first
concern may be
that this is obviously development on
what is a green field but if I'm not
correct it isn't Green Belt necessarily
that's correct yeah but it's not
developing on the Green Belt essentially
so it's no in terms of factual points
there it's not green belt development no
it's a green field Group you know it's a
it's a secondary area of environmental
sensitivity so you know as it is of some
landscape value
and
the way my consideration of this
application was that okay we're building
on a Green Field we can't keep doing
this
but then I actually think about the
impact on family farmers
and this is clearly a family farm
looking to diversify and make their Farm
Enterprise viable which is becoming even
more difficult in current circumstances
we've heard from the applicant we've
heard from objectives today
and it it looks to me that you know
every possible uh effort has been made
to mitigate those concerns
and for that reason if it is going to
enable farming within our district I
would be minded to support it with those
recommendations
uh thank you
uh
colleagues I've been heard everything
today and the officer's recommendations
before us what is the view of the
committee on the application
I am now opening the floor to motions
a move that we accept this application
with officers recommendations
uh
facts with officers I've made those
sorry to accept officer recommendations
um so we can take that to a vote please
uh thank you chair
councilor Cheatham
or
counselor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Fawcett
for
councilor Foster against
councilor girl
councilor Hancock against
councilor Hartson or
counselor Lacey for
councilor ligas against
councilor Rouse
that's eight for the
motion and three against the motion has
passenger
thank you
all right we'll now move on to the third
application item six on the agenda
um application Ned
22 0 stroke forward slash zero one
zero three six four slash o l romfield
okay oh sorry
um if you would like to leave well then
welcome to
your partner I have a speaker on that
in line with normal practices I'm going
to ask the planning officers to tell us
about that any late comments and give a
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans of the site
I will allow the officers to complete
the presentation again members unless
you have a point of order that you feel
cannot wait
can you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end
thank you
I just believe Phil speaking on this one
thank you Chad um there's no late reps
um this is now my application for the
demolition of existing buildings and the
direction of a food store matters of
appearance and Landscape in our reserve
for further approval with issues of
access layout and scale to do to be
determined at this stage
the application size in the center of
the screen and lies in the settlement
development limits for dronfield and is
a principal employment area
the town centralized to the South and to
the West Side backs onto the tree Bell
to the drum field bypass opposite the
side to employment units and the scout
this extract shows the employmentarian
purple and the Town Center hatched in
blue to the South are set out in the
report the development of the site for a
retail store is contrary to policy wc2
however the benefits in terms of
providing additional retail capacity
arising from existing stores over
trading in dronfield is considered
sufficient to justify the loss of
employment land on this side when
coupled with the fact that the overall
levels employment land across the
district remains well in excess of the
level required to deliver the employment
strategy set out in the plan
um this is a red line plan showing the
two existing buildings to demolished
these have been vacant for about two
years
this show was the layout which proposes
an improved access in the Southeast
Corner serving both the store and the
adjacent amateur site
the building will be to the rear of the
site with car park into the front 100
spaces are proposed and existing true
screen into the boundaries would largely
be retained
now this shows details of proposed
access the required visibility can be
achieved and new footways and pedestrian
Crossing are pose to encourage linkages
and
proposals also include access into the
ambitec car park to the South and to the
rear car park
and this is a 3D visual of the building
this shows it's set to three of the site
the new access arrangements and car
parking in front and the site is
elevated above the road however well
screened by existing trees
there's a review of the application side
to the top of the screen
the roundabouts are in Sainsbury's at
the bottom of the picture
highways have confirmed that the
development will not have an adverse
impact on the capacity of this Junction
and Sainsbury's in its car park as soon
to the right of the roundabout
it's a photo looking north towards the
existing access to the left is the hour
tech officers and car park
photograph opposite the site access
which will be wired and improved provide
entrance and exit for the store
it's photosho now we'll take entrance
and the existing site entrance
suppose to uh
sorry and this is a photo looking South
towards the site entrance from the
ponsford
um industrial unit and it's the
approximate location of The Pedestrian
Crossing
the port path will be extended on the
opposite side of the road
and this is a photo taken from the
skeletal entrance looking back towards
the application site on the opposite
side of the road
that's it thank you
thank you
as there are no speakers for this
application
we will move straight to questions to
officers
again I would like to keep this part of
the proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points you are not
sure of
so I would be grateful if you would not
move any motions at this stage
councilor Foster thank you chair uh
mine's a question but it's got a very
short Preamble something ever discussed
with Mr Slater already and with Bridget
gold at highways today it's regarding
figure three uh which I think that's on
page 71.
uh committee members will be able to see
there's a proposed pedestrian Crossing
there which is part of the section 278
agreement that's the works that uh the
developer will do uh in conjunction with
highways now it says there that it's
just a pedestrian Crossing so I'm
looking for uh some clarity from uh from
officers whether we can put down uh
whether this committee can put down as a
condition the type of the actual
pedestrian Crossing now my concern is
because reeks Lane itself there's only
uh as as other other councils may know
here
um cancer cheetah may know this
uh we've got uh we've got pathways on
both sides but as you get further down
recently and there's only pathway on one
side and the the average speed in this
third on this 30 mile an hour road is
quite High we know that from uh from
what we know that from experience and
from living there so it's it's on the
high side the average speed now
discussing this with uh Bridget gold and
it is a question chair but just to make
the committee aware first discussing
this with Bridget gold she's made it
clear that zebras are only good for
slow-moving traffic much like we've got
on on dronfield bottom what would be
more appropriate on here is either a
pelican or because of the scouter
opposite a puffing Crossing so a pelican
one with the lights where you press the
button for clarity
um so my question is
looking at how much they cost given that
uh little which is likely to be the the
owner of this uh are looking at putting
this Crossing in a zebra at the minute
to the count it costs about 40K to
install now a pelican cost 90 to 95.
those are the figures my concern is this
left alone this 278 as it is uh the a
developer will likely err on the uh the
cheaper side that's my concern what's
really needed here now the reason for
the question is this question went to
highways development control it didn't
go past development control to Bridget
gold who wouldn't normally comment on it
she she said she hadn't heard of this if
so her comments were this it's not
appropriate on this type of Road and as
zebra is fine for slow-moving traffic
and the very last thing I'd finish on
and thanks for for this chair for
letting me have some Preamble on this a
previous one was funded by little in
shirebrook shirebrook on Portland Road
so there uh little paid for one
um uh for a pelican Crossing now my
question is are we able to put this in
con a condition if can this committee
today put this in a condition the type
rather than just leave it down this
Crossing so the question is can we put
here today as a condition that it's a
pelican Crossing or a puffin Crossing
thank you chair
I think we can certainly put on a
condition that requires details of The
Pedestrian Crossing to be submitted and
approved in writing by the local
planning Authority
um
I take your point about little but
little aren't actually the applicants
for this so
um
I'll comment on whether they would be
able to pay or not so
um we can certainly put a condition on
requiring the details to be approved if
if committee are adamant that they want
the particular type of Crossing then yes
we can we can put that condition on as
well but like I say at this day's
um little aren't actually the applicants
if I can come back on that chair uh
they're obviously not the applicants
like they weren't on Portland Road
little wouldn't be the applicants
neither would Tesco neither would I like
but they will be the one that's taking
this on uh so if the answer is yes we
can put that condition on and that's the
committed to be a minded that that be a
condition on this
thank you chair
just clarify she's obviously got some
experience on this cancer cluster what
what would be the name of the crossing
that you just mentioned there that would
be
uh either Pelican yeah or a puffin
gotcha Apple thing's got uh I believe
the difference between a pelican and a
puffin there's a very slight difference
no joke there's a very slacker
difference and it's all about it being
detectable for younger children yeah the
deficient the definitions online but
yeah the main thing it would be light it
would involve lives and that's either a
pelican or a puffin and it would be
applicable in a place like this My worry
is when you're looking at a fancy
question when you're looking at a
company like little and it will belittle
we understand they will be here uh
they've got a turnover I think it was
7.8 billion last year they can afford
this whereas uh the County Council you
know they don't have as much money as
taxpayers money they should be able to
maybe pay this as part of a section 278
we're able to do it and that's what I
asked the committee to consider it will
be a concern in years to coming thank
you chair I'd be minded to support that
if we can have that as a um
as a recommendation
if I could just just be clear chair so
it would be the Puffin or the Pelican as
specified in the condition
yes
knowledge of birds
yep
right
um
thank you to the officers for that uh
this leads us to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we've
heard and what we think and what we want
to decide I would now like to open the
fall for debate
Council Foster yeah just commenting on
General uh my concern is when we look at
policy we use an employment land uh for
retail and what we're and we're
justifying it by using uh saying that
existing uh companies are all those
trading now that would be the the the
only two big uh supermarkets we've got
in dronfield are Sainsbury's and ALDI
and I just want the committee to be to
be minded that the silver trading you've
got to be careful because we don't have
the figures for this these are the
figures that have been provided by the
developers so it is a concern for me uh
this especially when I'm looking just a
few years ago I took I permission from
Aldi to take um a petition on their door
and as part of that petition and this is
quite well known in uh Council cheetah
might want to comment on this if you go
to alde and and you you don't always
find drum field resonance there the
petition I took half it was I think it
was 49 and 51 half came from Sheffield
so half of the people that shop at Aldi
and this was about five years back this
petition about half the people and uh I
took about 300 names on the uh over over
a weekend half of them came now the
reason why I mentioned it and mentioning
it that half came from Sheffield were
likely to see this at little as well
so it's not going to it's not a question
of over trading it's that people will
come from Sheffield they'll use Green
Lane and they'll use brochure uh and
traffic will increase and they'll use
that Junction it's not necessarily for
dronfield residents that doesn't mean
it's a bad thing but we've got to be
minded with that when we think about
traffic
and we're thinking about where these
people will come from they'll be coming
from a different County to shop in
Northeast Derbyshire we've got to
reminded that that's I believe what will
happen thank you chair
was old enough to remember when the
Sainsbury's was built and you could
argue that it put some of those
throughout the co-op at the Civic Center
out of business so uh
um it's difficult for me to give an
objective uh forecast of whether uh what
impacts our hypothenium at least on the
existing Aldi in Sainsbury's uh however
I do understand that the um the business
units agency at the moment uh it does
seem as good a place as any to put a
relatively small Supermarket
um yeah it probably will attract
Shoppers from Over the Border in in
Sheffield but I I don't really
necessarily think that's a bad thing
that um attracts you know business into
the into the town and obviously God said
remember this business school the other
way as well because people are shopping
at St James isn't made ahead now as well
so uh I'm sort of minded to support the
um application imbalance
thank you
yeah
thank you chair sorry just to um pick up
on the point about the um pedestrian
Crossing issue and just just for
clarification because at the moment the
recommendation
um doesn't have the caveat that
um the details or conditions being
delegated back to the the planning
manager for development management so
just to clarify when we get to the point
of uh voting on a recommendation my
suggestion would be that the the
recommendation is that that is delegated
back so that officers can have the
discussion with the applicant about the
uh wording that's being debated
um and should they not agree then we may
not have to come back but if if they did
agree that that was part of the
delegated decision today thanks chair
okay Council again
yeah I'm also very familiar with this
area as I live in Marsh Lane and it is
already quite busy with traffic and I
certainly support your points about that
being a fast Road I mean I don't think
it matters whether people are coming
from Sheffield or John Field or wherever
but it does seem like a lot of
supermarkets in a small area we've got
the Sainsbury's but possibly this one
and as you say the Audi which really
isn't that far away so I would have
concerns about increased traffic in what
is already a busy traffic area
okay
all right no more uh on that um we'll
haven't heard everything today and
officers recommendations before us uh
what is the the view of the committee on
the application and I am now opening the
floor to motions
I'll move the um we um accept the
officer's recommendations with the under
with the edition of the Council of
Fosters Amendment
um that we
insist on their Pelican or was it a bird
Crossing for things that was it yeah
David Attenborough on the committee
thank you
we've got Seth in there for that or are
we are we moving it more towards the
recommendations as they get planning
officer about taking it back to
if you can just clarify that
I think chair like I say if the
recommendation is amended so that the
the planning manager for development
management has delegated powers to have
this discussion with the applicant so
that if they are willing to agree to
what committee is debated I.E include
provision for Puffin or Pelican Crossing
then it would be delegated to office to
then issue a decision should they
disagree we may well have to come back
uh well or it would be coming back right
now
proposal yes yes this is mandate the
opposite recommendations with the
arthritis to have the delegated
discussion with the Developers
that's easy for me to say
we've got a second after that
thank you counselor out all right we'll
take that to the vote then
okay chair I think um that's entirely
clear so it's to approve officer
recommendations subject to um the uh the
delegation to actually have the
discussion over the puff and stroke
Pelican Crossing
uh councilor Chisholm or
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
counselor forces
or
counselor Foster against
councilor girl
against
councilor Hancock for
counselor or
councilor Lacey or
councilor ligas against
councilor Rouse
that's 7-4 the motion three against and
one abstains the motion is pasture
thank you
all right we'll now move on to the
fourth application
um this is Ned forward slash 23 forward
slash zero zero three eight one slash F
L reckon field
in line with normal practices I'm going
to ask the plumbing officers to tell us
about any late comments and give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site I will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end
and I believe Kerry's taking this one
thanks chair um I'm Kerry Helen one of
the planning officers and this is an
application for um full planning
permission for the conversion and change
abuse of the building with extensions
for the two-story dwelling with roof
lights in the provision of a package
sewage treatment plant site is located
outside of a settlement development
limit and lies in open Countryside
the site is also located in an area
defined as a primary area of multiple
environmental sensitivity these
Landscapes are considered to be the most
sensitive landscape areas of landscape
within Northeast Derbyshire the main
planning considerations here are whether
or not the proposal meets the council's
conversion policy is of an appropriate
design and whether or whether the
proposals will cause significant harm to
the landscape setting
no statutory Consultants have identified
any technical reasons as to why this
application should be refused
the aerial photograph shows the
applications that are highlighted in
yellow and the surrounding area
white Colleen is to the west of the
application site land surrounding the
site is an open Countryside which as
outlined previously is a sensitive
landscape setting
and this is just a zoomed in view of the
application site white car Lane runs
north to south through the center of the
image a small number of Residential
Properties are in the vicinity of the
site
um this is the site location plan which
shows the extent of the application site
outlined in red including the access
onto white car Lane they're joining land
in the applicant's ownership is shown
outlined in blue the existing dwelling
benefits from two accesses one to the
north which is included in this
application and one to the south of the
existing dwelling
um so this shows the existing and sorry
the existing elevations and floor plans
of the building as can be seen the
building is a simple single story
three-bay garage so over two levels
and this slide shows the proposed
elevations and floor plans of the
building the proposals include extending
the building to the west to our 2.2
meters lowering the floor level of the
main section of the building by 0.9
meters to be level with the Eastern
section raising the region Eaves of the
Eastern section by 0.9 meters and
extending the front elevation of the
Eastern element forward by 0.6 meters
the structural survey submitted with the
application concludes that a full
replacement of the roof structure would
also be required
um so just some photos and this is from
the rear of the building from White Car
Lane and the application building
um is shown there in the middle of the
photo when the applicant's property
carbon Farm is shown on the right as you
can see the building is set at a lower
land level than white car Lane
um this is just a photo of the of the
building from within the site
uh this is a photo of the site from
White Car Lane two parking spaces are
proposed
um just in this section here and then a
visitor space on the graveled area there
this is a photo from
um of the photo showing existing access
and the building the existing dwelling
in views towards oxton Reservoir
and this is a photo from school Lane
looking north towards the application
site and the outbuilding can be seen
there in the middle of the photo
and so officers of the view that the
extent of the works would go beyond a
conversion as it would require
substantial alterations and extensions
and therefore wouldn't be compliant with
local plan policy ss9 or SDC one
moreover it is considered that the
proposals would result in an
unacceptable impact on the rural
character of the area and the poses
would fail to respect conserva enhance
the local distinctive local landscape
area and therefore the proposals will be
contrary to ss1 ss9 sdc3 and SDC 12 the
local plan
and policies within the brackenfield
neighborhood plan all of the technical
matters are discussed within the
committee report accordingly officers
are recommending the application is um
to be refused and just a final note that
the reference um references made within
the committee report to SDC one however
reference this policy is not included in
the reason for refusal so if members are
minded to go with the recommendation I'd
advise a reference to this policy is
included within that
thank you chair
thank you
all right guys we are three speakers on
the application the first of them will
be Tim stubbins the agent uh they will
have three minutes to get over their
points they will be informed when 30
seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your questions should only
relate to the points which they have
already made
right Mr Steuben
thanks chair thanks committee my name is
Tim stubbins I'm a partner with Mitchell
Proctor Architects I've been there a
long time too long ago to tell you about
still uh prior to submitting this
application I did uh consult with Mr
Graham Cooper
in respect of the proposed conversion
and in respect to its size and scale or
the size and scale of additions
it did tell me in writing that there is
no guidance as to what is modest or
significantly larger in the local plan
uh
from experience and going back a long
number of years there used to be a rule
of thumb which was a rule of thumb I
think
talked about 30 percent
anyway we've increased the length of the
building by two meters
a percentage increase of approximately
25 percent
which we believe is an acceptable
increase in the floor area
our design
does not increase the ridge height
of the principal Bond building and on a
slightly increases the ridge height of
the Eastern Building
we have lowered the floor area to suit
our clients need to give a lower ground
floor
the alterations are disgust and with
reference to the photographs that the
planning officers is posted the
alterations cannot be seen from any of
the roads
and so we can't see why the the the
alterations are proposed uh from you
know our visual effect on the rural
character of the area
uh notwithstanding out the plane officer
in a report says that the conversion
with a modest extension may be
considered acceptable
the report also says that there aren't
any Highway objections the building is
structurally Sound a fit of a conversion
not withstanding this it does need a new
roof as does every Barn conversion
Life Trust of no objections either
and so we only see the principal reason
for you for your
for your rejection or to refuse it
is is what is seen to be acceptable or
not there's a modest extension
this is obviously a match with 30
seconds remain as there's no guidance
furthermore there are many examples
where the authorities have approved much
larger extensions uh in the vicinity of
the application site in my class I refer
to these
so in this respect uh we think our
what was this satisfactory
uh it would have been helpful as an
aside if the planning office to join the
course of the application time chair
acquainted us with their issues
thank you uh do any members have any
questions for the speaker Council Costa
thank you chair uh I'm asking questions
on things you've mentioned uh and
nothing else uh as as is the norm you
said there's no Guidance just to give a
fair crack uh to your uh to your
applicants and the people you're
representing you said there's no
guidance but when you look at in offices
recommendations and I'm sure you'll read
them it's contrary to policies or it's
in the office's opinion contrary to
policies ss1 the overarching policy ss9
SDC 3 12 and then uh policies of the
brackenfield neighborhood plan ch1 ch2h1
so we've got guidance already that's the
guidance we have as a planning committee
and that's what I would follow when I'm
looking at offices recommendations and
that's so that's my guidance so you see
there's no guidance have you got any
comments at all any general comments
around that no guidance and what I would
consider guidance
uh sorry can you use your microphone
please
in the gardens we got from Graham it
says categorically that there isn't any
guidance to Quantum
and so when you look at as we're looking
look acting for our client looking at
extensions of the books on buildings you
know all over the district there seems
to be a lack of uh
uniformity and approach really uh
mcclatch obviously got a purpose for the
building which they've described uh and
they are
within eyesight of other barn
conversions where
to be honest
far greater extensions have been put on
so that's what I'm trying to get at uh
just a chance your question thank you
thank you next speaker on this is uh
Michael Paul the applicant
you know three minutes when you're ready
thank you
um yeah
um my name is Michael Poole I'm the
applicant um
just to follow on from Tim
um we we invited Kerry Allen out because
we were
worried about the armfulness
um and the size of the extension because
we lived in Derbyshire all his life with
Liberty it's just a wonderful place and
we invited Kerry out and we asked her
how it would be harmful to the
countryside
and during the meeting we sort of really
didn't get an understanding how it would
be harmful to the countryside
um and I asked her what size extension
we could go for and we couldn't really
get an answer to that as far as size and
you know quantity so after that
um
I did a bit of research into this
because I see I drive from our house
into Chesterfield every day so I see a
lot of things going off I see buildings
I could see how many bricks are going on
a building every day because I pass them
and I looked into it and I looked at a
place in uh just down the road in
Milltown where they did a conversion
from a barn to a dwelling and it had a
35 extension on it and that was passed
by a planning committee and then also
our next door neighbors on the same road
as us on White Car Lane it's quite a
it's an Old Farm there's been certain
things going on there and there's a barn
on that particular development which
Northeast Derbyshire structural engineer
says it wasn't capable of converting and
what they've done now they've built an
um an extension on it which is around
about 65 and they've demolished it by
about 70 percent
and I'm thinking well if that's not
harmful to the countryside you know wise
as harmful to the countryside based on
25 floor space so we're just trying to
get his head around that I mean and
that's from the same local plan as ours
November November 2021 and
um
it's highly visible it's you can see it
from the roadside as you drive fast as
an invisible from the from the north
elevation of the rear and there's only a
small extension on it which is two
meters from the front of it you can't
really see it I know there's a picture
on there from
um School Lane which is right down the
bottom but it's it's you know you need
some good eyesight to see it really or
you know it's not very visible at all
um and I emailed all this information
about this development next to us over
to Kerry and the copied Adrian Kirkham
in Graham Cooper
and um I didn't really get any response
to the phone Carry and she said well I
didn't have anything to do with this um
30 seconds remain and um you know I have
no further comments to add to it so it
left it a bit in limbo really to what we
could so when we can see all these
things going off and uh you know we
couldn't understand why you know they
wouldn't support this application so I'm
just asking you the counselors if you
would support it thank you
thank you have any members any questions
about the points which speaker has made
in their presentation
nope right we've got one more speaker
this is uh this is Billie Jean Paul also
the applicant
hello thanks for inviting me today
um excuse me my voice is a bit weird
um just wanted to say that um we're not
looking to property from the site at all
it will be a family home or family home
and excuse me we have two children
living with us uh we love the area we
want to stay in the area but because
prices and costs have gone up you know
we're looking to downsize so we are
looking to stay and it will be our
family home it won't be a holiday lips
and we're also thinking that actually uh
we will stay there for as long as
possible if the plane got passed but it
will be an affordable home for some
other family in the area currently
there's no development opportunities at
all within the brackenfield area
um as my husband said it can only be
seen from the north elevation excuse me
um so Walkers you know can see it but
it's actually a minor minimal change
um but in terms of landscaping that will
all be dry Stone walled will plant it
all with plants it'll be or the fencing
will be all replaced
um so it will look absolutely beautiful
from the lane with minimal impact
um and as we've said we feel that the
two meter extension albeit yes will go
down but the ridge height won't increase
um is modest and we don't we don't feel
you can get more bodies than a two meter
extension and obviously we do need three
bedrooms because we've got two children
so we need to make sure they've got a
roof over their head
um but I just wanted to express my
thoughts that it's not going to be it's
not for our profiteering it's for a
family home obviously we will sell the
property that we currently live in and
there's no issues there from the council
um either have been overlooked or
anything like that also we do support
the local farmers because we owned it
excuse me the field in front of us and
the field at the side of us and
obviously they they read the crops every
year we give them those crops so these
we do support the local area
um and that's really all I wanted to say
I'm so sorry about my voice I've had an
operation on my throats I can't speak
very well but
um I just wanted to to make sure you you
knew what it was for and the purpose
thank you for that and do I remember
members have any questions about the
points which speaker has made
in the presentation
nope thank you you can thank your seat
all right guys you will now have the the
opportunity to put questions to officers
about the application again I would like
to keep this part of the proceedings
focused on getting clarity about any
points you are not sure of so I would be
grateful if you could not move any
motions at this stage
does anybody have any questions for
officers Council info
thanks chair
um
this is kind of a similar question no to
what one of the applicants has just
asked because obviously the guidance is
that it's not detrimental to the
countryside and the mppf is that
um
development of a redundant auditions
building enhances its immediate setting
so I'm kind of trying to balance why
bringing a redundant building into use
in some description without a massive
change where deeming to be detrimental
rather than enhancing
foreign
I think in terms of the um
the sorry can you can you just repeat
your question again yeah what why are we
because we right now we've got a
redundant building haven't we it's it's
not really any use and it's not an
eyesore it's actually quite a nice
building although it's tired
um so I'm I'm trying to determine why in
your head
doing it up is actually going to be
detrimental rather because they're not
really building anything new are they
it's not putting something there that
doesn't already exist it is extending
its likely so what what what's actually
the the thing that in your head is
tipping it over to being detrimental
rather than enhancing so I think the
building as it is is quite a simple
three-bay a single story
um garage as it is the works that I
appreciate the the floor space is only
increasing by
um 25 but the volume of the building is
increasing significantly and when the
works when you look at the works that
are proposed yes it is an extension to
the side but it's also lowering the
floor level and then extensions to the
Eastern element as well so the volume
does increase
um significantly it's of a traditional
built rural building at the moment and
the change would make it
um harmful to the character of the
building and then have an impact on the
on the countryside and Landscape as well
Council bullet thanks chair yeah it's
similar to what councilor Hancock has
said that what would have to materially
change in this application for it to
have a realistic Prospect of being
approved
thank you and the the conversion
and the applicant join the application
say that I think there's something of a
Commodore straight conversion that the
building would be supported by policy
and but obviously the policy
doesn't allow for major alterations or
adaptations to the building and officers
of the view that the extent of the works
of they are proposing and doesn't comply
with that conversion policy so I think
there is scope to do something on the
side but it would be more of a
sympathetic conversion of the existing
building rather than the works that
they're proposing
thank you
no other questions for officers
uh thank you for that this leads us to
the final part of the process our
discussion about what we've heard what
we think and what we want to decide our
now allowed to open the floor for debate
absolutely good thank you
um well I do know this area very well
um
and I would I I know the property that
they've been explaining about further up
the road it was an old
um derelict Farm that's been
um
so is being as we speak extended Etc but
as far as all the other extensions in
that area
I think they were long before the
brackenfield neighborhood plan and long
before the local plan
um there's a massive difference between
the house they're living in now and the
house they're proposing to build it's
extreme downsizing
uh and I definitely disagree with Mr
stubbins when he says that it can't be
seen
from any roads because it can be seen
from three roads very easily it really
is in the middle of the open Countryside
you can see that building and the only
way it's hidden is if you're approaching
from the other side of the house that
they currently live in because it's
right behind it but from From The Bottom
Road going across the brackenfield
common from high ordish from White Car
Lane from the foot path it it really is
really out in the open you can see it
for Miles actually
um
and
I know we've not got to that stage yet
but uh I personally would like to
propose that we follow office as
recommended Nations for all the policies
listed because
you know well we can do that
thank you
any other comments cancel it thank you
chair and I'm struggling with this one
because you know we when we look through
the planning issues and principle of
development the paragraph eight of the
mppf one point within that there are a
couple of points that state things that
that I'm not really reading but the
there is one point or two points within
that the development would be to reuse a
redundant or disused building and
Analysis immediate setting
I'm struggling because there are points
within all this principle of development
that you could read yourself and quite
agree with I I I'm I'm with David on
this one and and Heather to somebody
great it's a chicken and egg thing I
read through sort of this SDC one where
they say you know about the Balkan
design and the ReUse without major
alterations and adaptations do we
consider that major I think the the
applicant has actually tried with our
planning team to get their their take on
it it's not exactly doing it on
retrospective planning or anything like
that
so I'm struggling with it
I'm I'm almost mindful to go against
officer recommendation but uh you know I
see points on from both sides
thank you thank you
any other comments no
thanks colleagues having good everything
today and the officer's recommendations
before us
which is a view of the committee
committee on the application I am now
opening the floor to motions
counselor house thank you can I say that
we go we offered recommendations please
cancel that I'll second that chair
well third
right we'll take that to the world
nature the motion is to approve officer
recommendations
councilor Chisholm oh
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
Council of forces
councilor Foster or
counselor
councilor Hancock against
councilor Hartson or
counselor Lacey oh
and councilor Rouse
that's eight for the motion two against
and one abstains the motion is pasture
thank you you can leave the channel
thank you
all right I think now offices are in
place we'll move on to the uh fifth
application
in one of our normal practices I'm going
to ask the planning officers to tell us
about any late comments and give any
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans of the site I will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
other questions about the process Until
the End uh and this is application
Ned forward slash 23 or slash zero zero
one five five four slash FL drum field
okay
I'm one of the planning officers
um the application in front of you is a
proposed single story rear extension
raises part of the existing roof to
accommodate a bedroom
um and an ensuite area with with a side
facing dorm or window a well of side
facing dorm or beg your pardon Phillips
roof Windows the Juliet Balcony to the
rear the Shakespeare Crescent at
drumfield
site
is uh located within the settlement
development limit of dronfield and
within an area
um of mid to late 20th century dwellings
the
um open land you see to the South and
part part to the Northeast is part of
the Greenbelt of North establishing
excuse me Ken can I just ask you to
speak more directly into the mic thanks
okay
is that better
just let me move things around a little
bit
so yeah that that's uh within the that's
the Northeast Derbyshire Green Belt just
to recap there
uh whether the site is in the settlement
development location
the arrangement of dwellings on site
um and in the area is not of a uniform
front or rear building line so there is
some staggering between the two but they
are closely related to one another
on the side
and that can be seen within the proposed
location and the proposed plans
the proposed elevation the proposed
elevations show a
um two level effect on the roof to the
to the front
and that is
um at the height of one meter and it's
3.7 meters back from the principal
elevation creating a two level effect
from the highway and serving to reduce
the impact when viewed from from the the
highway itself
there are to be four roof lights in the
southern
um elevation which is uphill in this
case
and then on the Northern elevation there
is to be a Dharma and there are to be
three four baking pardon proposed
windows in that Dormer with the Juliet
Balcony to the rear
as can be Illustrated there
the single story rear extension beg your
pardon the single story rear extension
will replace the conservatory
and we'll extend right across the
um rear elevation of the of the site
and we'll have two windows to the
northern
um elevation as shown on the plan to the
bottom right of the screen as you look
at it
that this this picture just shows you
the existing and proposed plan so it
shows you clear on that so there's a
little bit of clarity on that
now they these are some photos that are
important to consider as as part of the
considerations you've got to make
um
this shows the relationship at the rear
between the site to the Northeast which
is number 80 and the site to the
Southwest which is number 78 and bear in
mind that the Juliet Balcony is to the
rear in the center of that elevation and
number 80 which is the one downhill is
the is where the dorm is going to be
placed
um we have had an objection from number
80.
and the objection from number 80
covers two matters the first is
maintenance which is a private and civil
matter and and should be dealt with with
the applicant and their neighbor
the other part of that is about the
overlooking of the the rear most of the
Dormer windows and the two side facing
windows in the rear extension
um however the
um applicant uh the object to Biggie
pardon also states that should they be
obscure glazed they would not have an
objection to those windows and in the
report it is suggested that we take a
condition in order to deal with that
matter
there is there's another photo dealing
with the
um relationship with number 78
and you can see that it is upheld but
the the original dwellings also had side
facing Windows as well
and again number eight to where the uh
the possibly the key relationship in
terms of amenity on site
and that's the end of the presentation
thank you all right College we have no
speakers on this application so we will
move straight in onto questions to the
officers
thank you it is the center Bungalow the
building on isn't it you know when you
go back go back a
couple of pictures
for my benefit
yeah I'll just get the they're with me a
second while
yeah you see in that in the photo there
it's the one to the left with the open
controller
um
Conservatory door
we're talking about the elevation
pointing down or not during the job
it's almost like a conservative
no that's that's true and it is a
conservatory having been on site
because on that side it's similar
but that's I mean that's that's that's
the situation that you need to make a
decision on
I think those are that extension's
probably been done under permitted
development over time and you know
people have bought that property knowing
that situation yeah yeah
one more questions okay
uh thank you to the answers for that
leads on to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we're
verb what we think and what we want to
decide I would now like to open the
floor for debate
he looks a relatively um
non-controversial development
competitive a lot of the ones that we um
deal with so I can't really see a huge
problem with it
and so they say uh chair can I move that
we accept this in a sentence
yeah I I want to move that we accept
pictures
um are you actually ending the
discussion at this point no not yet okay
so nobody else
wants to attend to the debate no
all right members
um
having heard everything today and the
officer's recommendations before us what
is the view of the committee on the
application and now opening the floor to
motions
uh chair I moved to uh we accept this is
uh recommendations
psychology
thank you
all right we'll move to the vote
and let's just
sorry councilor Cooper can you just
clarify is that with or without
um the clear glass what is that
is that within that condition that that
glass is not clear basically yeah can
you please clarify that the answer is
yes uh Council Copo uh it's with the uh
change the gazing yeah
the obscure
if I may just uh just to be clear so in
the list of conditions we've got the
proposed side facing window is going to
be obscure the glazed so I believe the
recommendation was in accordance with
officer recommendation wasn't it
all right uh we're going to take a roll
call on that then
so it's to approve officer
recommendations with that clarification
which we've just received at the opaque
windows are already part of the
conditions
uh councilor Chisholm so
councilor Cooper
counselor alias
Council of forces for councilor Foster
or councilor girl
councilor Hancock for councilor Hanson
for
councilor Lacy for councilor Liggett for
councilor Rouse
uh the votes unanimous share the motion
has passed
thank you
all right we'll now move on to the
section final uh application
um in line with our normal practices I'm
going to ask the planning officers tell
us about any late comments and to give a
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans on site this is application
Ned or 23
400457 forward slash FL windworth
thank you chair
um there have been no uh late
representations made of committee and
this plan and application seeks
permission for a single story
um flat roof rear extension a loft
conversion and the creation of a
low-level retaining Garden walked from a
patio the application is report to the
planning committee in line with the
council's Constitution as the applicant
is an employee at Northeast Derbyshire
Council and works within the planning
team the application site is located
within the settlement development limits
for wingworth where domestic extensions
are acceptable in principle and
the statutory Consultants of raised no
reasons to refuse the application
as you can see from the next slide this
plan illustrates the application site
shaded in yellow the development will be
to the rear of the property
with the only changes being uh with the
only changes to the front being the
inclusion of Velux Windows which could
be constructed under permitted
development
um then on this slide you've got a more
zoomed in version of the application
site in the surrounding area which
illustrates the residential setting and
as you can see from it there are quite
large three Gardens as well
um this is the official site location
plan with the site edged in red and you
can see Central Drive running to the
South and the galans are adjunction to
the southeast
and Central Drive extends west of the
application site
and on this slide
you have
um your existing plans running across
the top with existing elevations and an
existing floor plan
hello you have proposed elevations and
then in the bottom left corner you have
your first floor plan which highlights
the rear patio
and the rear extension and the Velux
windows and the roof the rear extension
will measure approximately 4.25 meters
in length six meters wide and we'll have
a high of 2.6 to match the eaves of the
original dwelling
the proposed materials will match the
host well in and
um
although as previously stated the Velux
roof lights are included they're only
there for the
um completeness of the application and
they can be built under permitted
development
and the patio to the rear demonstrates
the
um the the retaining wall which will be
approximately 600 millimeters High
and next I do have some site photos
and the present red arrow is just
illustrative of an approximate location
for the rear extension
and
um the next photo is a view from further
down the garden which illustrates the
relationship between the application
site and the two neighboring properties
and that is the end of my presentation
thank you chair
thank you
uh we have no speakers on this
application so we'll go straight to uh
onto questions to the officers again I
would like to keep this part of the
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points that you are not sure
of so I'd be grateful if you would not
move any motions
at this stage
I have no questions for officers no no
uh Curtis uh has there been any letters
of objection from immediate neighbors no
thank you very much
thank you about Curtis and well done on
you first report to the planning
committee
uh this leaders at the final part of the
process our discussion about what we
heard what we think uh and what we want
to decide I would like to open the floor
for debate
yeah given given the the size of the
properties either side I think it's just
a small development on the rear of a
building I don't see any issue at all
thank you Council Elliott
uh right members uh
haven't heard everything today
um the office of recommendation before
us what is a view of the committee on
the application and I am now opening the
floor to motion chair I'll move after
recommendation
he beats counselor and cook
right it will take a vote on that uh my
roll call
Elsa Chisholm whoa
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
Council of forces
for
councilor Foster or
counselor
councilor Hancock for
councilor Hudson for
councilor Lacey for
and councilor Liggett for
the voters unanimous shirt the motion
has passed
thank you
uh and I found the planning officers to
explain the next report item 11 appeals
lodged undetermined
thank you chair
um just to kind of briefly go through
the report really uh in terms of the
appeals lodged um you'll see that there
are three there probably the one to
highlight is that the 36 dwellings the
third one
um outline application at uh Kalo uh I
think Graham will correct me if I'm
wrong here but I think we're waiting on
um from the planning inspector in terms
of how that appeal will actually be
handled
um probably whether it's uh going to be
an informal hearing or an inquiry
basically
um in terms of the appeals allowed
um the the first one the 397 dwellings
uh upper thought Pro killer Marsh I
think uh members are probably familiar
with that one
um at the moment we are waiting on the
costs decision the applicant or the
appellant applied for costs uh as part
of that appeal so we're still waiting on
that having Chase dependent Spectrum for
it so I think probably that's going to
be worthy of further discussion uh once
we've got that that cost decision and we
can consider that in the round yeah
excuse sorry to intro picture has there
been any indication on that so far
um disappointment the questions later
uh so just briefly chat uh on the
um appeals dismissed
um they actually both relate to the same
site uh in Westington
um and relate to uh the the first one is
actually
um so retention of an agricultural
implement store
um so we're currently considering
um enforcement action potentially there
depending on uh whether the the
appellant uh wants to work with us to uh
look at an alternative scheme
um and that the second one also related
to that same site so I had nothing else
to add share I can respond to the
yeah if you would
so um yeah like I say we've had the
appeal decision through
um in relation to up thought bro killer
Marsh uh we're waiting on the the cost
decision there hasn't been any
indication
um and basically the decision will be
either
um no Award of costs partial or full
Awards um we're waiting we haven't had
anything and we know that the applicant
for reasons probably self-explanatory is
also chasing um so we haven't heard
anything on that I think
um I'm in the planning inspector like
there's a planning department uh
measured on their performance in terms
of timeliness of issuing actual
decisions on the planet appeal
um the costs decision can follow so
we're in that period basically
no more questions no oh sorry cancel the
ticket no sorry I just wondered
um I realized that this has been appeal
lodged in shurland I just wondered why
it wasn't on on here it was the um
it was a major development 90 something
houses speeds uh off whole field Gate
Lane oh I'm being waved that's at the
right
thank you members uh do we agree to note
the report
oh no
I have no urgent business so now declare
the meeting closed thank you for your
attendance